foreign
looks forward to getting the first shift of the
Season under their belt you think about it all
year there's anxiety wrapped around it some more
for some than others but Gabriel velardi a key
cog in that three-player deal that came from La
in exchange for Pierre Luke Dubois expectation
on him more than he's ever experienced before
it'll be nice to get this under his belt and
get down the road of being a jack back behind
his back to the flank it was a shot that never
was he should have shot try flee to the side of
the net good pass unless well that's something
Jets fans hope to see a lot of this see Power
Play goal it's one nothing would have been
[Applause]
yeah that's what they want to see this is
something that the Jets have not practiced
very much at all it was just this morning
in pre-game ski where they went over it
for the first time with this group of
five but you're right really efficient
Puck moving look at the spin away pass
from velardi so he draws attention to
himself and he made that extra pass last
time well this one turned out perfect
agreed and it's remarkable how you know his foot
speed that speaks for itself but the fact that his
hand speed and his foot speed are matching each
other already he looks excellent and it's just
game one of the preseason for him there's Jeff BL
initiated contact ended up wiping out with core
checking by Reichel BL in the corner now is passed
for Reichel here's a chance good stop Gustafson
robbed by Calvin Pickard the best save at either
end of this game if the Jets up one here at home
not Dave Petrov waits for some help sweeps it
over Cody CC down to the corner to Malone the
mirror machine of Brunswick Bernie to Cece
with the drive right on no crowd in front
CeCe gets it again Jets need a clear Bernie
kulak alone gave it right back pull back to
Cece it looked like a power play it's not below
to CC one time or a wild one big bounce off the
board jump around a tip and lavois cannot
tie the game for Edmonton 20 23-24 [Music]
took it away from Connor back for it 78 for gold
or gold former she went again with cataract here's
a chance now for Barrett tease it up to Perry
with a shot left link save by Calvin Pickard
looking for that second goal of the game did
not come the third period is underway really
glad you could join us tonight and uh it's CeCe
moving it ahead stolen away by velardi we've
talked about him a ton tonight he's been
strong the Rex had toward the net Malone
is there picker trying to freeze it he can't
do it Morrissey winning for the pass but it's
not a good one he'll have to go back and find
it gave it back to Kyle Connor Connor shifley
collected by Griffin Seth Griffith fifth round
pick in 2012 with the Bruins domestic off turning
away with it he'll race up the ice glad domestic
off the trailer is capari domestic on peock score
Morgan Baron was in front don't know if he got a
piece Pio took the shot it's two nothing Winnipeg
this is where it starts in the d-zone it was
peon early that stood up and caused the puck
to exchange hands and then Sandberg
Falls that up so both D did a really
good job making plays without the puck so
that you can play with it it's a good job
in domesticov with a little curl up and
then pioch able to skate right into this
one as he steps into it shot to the net I
think it went in clean ing Griffith [Music]
the power play for Edmonton off the rush here's
uh the king to the net of a bull rather that has
kicked away good save by brassoir to the net on
his forehand that's not an easy Puck to get to the
net we have to turn the corner left-handed shot
coming off the left wing and Holloway the 14th
pick in the 2020 draft now with the circle lavois
Janine five on three here for Edmondson side of
the net couldn't stick there but it's caught in
Hell by broswa for this team for a lot of years
[Applause] [Music]
for the Jets had a couple of options there off
the Russian viel unable to make it a three-nothing
game Puck comes three and the orders playing
possession that is the king head up the trailer
Cody CeCe with a shot no it did not cross the
line the referee run there to see it was on the
red but not over now Conor the other way teasing
up stopped rebound that was almost on the Carter's
stick as things open up and now an icing call
against the orders who almost had one right there
up on that play the shot and it's just trickling
offensively and then in return he made a good
defensive play at the other end of the ice makes
the save and gets enough of a piece of it to keep
it out so close [Applause] justice has checked
on the play rikel comes in as well for Winnipeg
you're the referee saying move viel
Stanley Long Shot scores that was tipped
in the circle it may be veal a point
shot makes it three nothing Winnipeg
I think this one will be awarded to number
19. nice job winning a battle get it from
low to high and then look at the bodies in
the lane and there's gases and does a good
job fighting to get his stick loose good job
from Big Logan Stanley to just get the puck to
the right area tip the puck changes Direction
and it's enough to beat Pickett on the move
was Morrissey missed that pass now they keep
it on side domestic cop for Baron for capari
right back to Morgan Baron good summary there
and another save here's domestic Hawk here's
a chance for more to see and he ripped that
one wide what Pickard has been strong tonight
salomonson sluck pass back handed tip by
Baron jets look really good off the rush
that time on the perimeter it is domestic off
back to Morrissey Vlad domesticon Morrissey
on the left side at the Circle centering
pass Baron shoots and scores [Applause]
Morgan Baron makes it four nothing Winnipeg
so deceptive and he holds the puck over to
Morrissey and right there he makes it look
easy Baron with no one near him all eyes on number
44 and the hard-working shift in this fourth line
pass goes off a stick Ford will hustle after
it gets to it gives it back to salomonson
walks tees it up couple of the uncle does not
shoot it one of the orders without a stick
scores Kyle cover the uncle with a nice wrist
shot and it's five nothing Winnipeg [Music]
it was an excellent retrieval there for Parker
Fort right there two on one and he just gets
the puck out in high ice and Humboldt this
the release from copper Bianca no Panic at
all patience he waits for an angle and a lane
to the net that he likes and I'll tell you he
has bred a lot of trust for me we talked about
14 games last year and he was a guy that didn't
play very much but when he got his opportunity
yes they've worked well together of course it
is a preseason game they're not against NHL
caliber players but the first I passed has
been a very good one between those three yeah I
would agree it's been fun to watch here tonight
because this one winds down so the Jets
went into Edmonton last night won the
shootout different lineup for both teams
tonight it was one nothing for the longest
time they pull away and they win their
second game five nothing over Edmonton